[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que j'aime ce que vous n'avez pas dû
série c'est eux se regarde et on a
repris ou qui va se mettre une note lui
aussi après leur sévère
voilà j'ai pas du temps du jeu de se
mettre à 10 vous l'étiez dit cela à
jean-marc oui pas moi non à vous combien
à moi 1,85 no kids et sévérine autre âge
me plante dans deux secondes la hausse a
atteint presse portait regard regard
regarde la ancian je la pose et là tout
le monde fait la chorégraphie que je
leur ai demandé de faire à part moi
j'aime vraiment j'aime bravo vous êtes
honnête contrairement aux personnes ici
présentes
[Musique]
est ce que vous allez refaire danse avec
les stars c'est la question que je
voulais vous poser avant la pause
est ce que vous allez resigner parce
qu'il va avoir une nouvelle saison danse
avec les stars
après un succès pareil c'est sûr vous
avez resigné ou pas en toute honnêteté
oui on vient juste de finir en quatre
mois
quand même formidable mais inferno parce
que c'est une émission qui est très dur
à faire je vais me donner au moins six
mois avant de avant de resigner on sait
même pas encore si on là l'année
prochaine
c'est quoi si vous n'ont pas encore
proposé donc tu es encore quoi c'est
vrai c'est parfait c'est pour faire
monter la saison j'aimerais bien non non
vous savez revient de refermer cette
émission c'est un ca c'est une belle
émission à faire mais elle est très dur
à faire ah ouais et donc on y repense
beaucoup avant de la drogue provenait
l'adorent mais elle est dure et pas
encore pris votre décision
non pas encore ce qui est dû au prix
monte là ce qui est dur les jus être un
être le juge de samedi soir c'est
formidable on s'amuse énormément c'est
la fête la direction artistique toute la
semaine c'est un travail qui est un
boulot de rêve une position de rêve pour
moi
mais ce sont des heures interminables et
c'est un travail de fou pour vraiment
proposer un spectacle comme ça toutes
les semaines
donc donc bon on vous sait